die Energiewende ist nicht gescheitert
sondern sie war von Anfang an eine
Totgeburt die Physik der Energietechnik
ist zu 100% bekannt genauso sicher wurde
auch das Scheitern der Energiewende
bereits vor Jahrzehnten vorhergesagt
stehen mal kein Wind und keine Sonne zur
Verfügung wie das in Deutschland jetzt
im Moment seit Wochen der Fall ist muss
Deutschland sich komplett aus den
konventionellen Kraftwerken versorgen
und diese Situation wird immer und immer
wieder auftreten und Behauptungen wir
könnten den Strom einfach speichern sind
einfach falsch
dass man nun neben Kohle auch noch die
besten Kernkraftwerke der Welt mutwillig
zerstört zeigt nur eines dass es den
Betreibern dieser Deindustrialisierung
überhaupt nicht um Klimawandel oder eine
CO2-Reduktion geht
so groß kann die angebliche Gefahr die
von Kernenergie ausgeht gar nicht sein
dass sie größer ist sogar als die
täglich verbreiteten Katastrophen
Warnungen durch den Klimawandel und
dabei reden wir hier nur von den
Kernkraftwerken wie sie heute laufen die
vor Jahrzehnten entwickelt wurden wenn
Deutschland nur einen winzigen Bruchteil
der energiewendekosten in die
Entwicklung moderner mini-reaktoren
gesteckt hätte ein weltweit übrigens
höchst innovativer Sektor werden wir
jetzt schon ein ganzes Stück weiter wir
selbst also unsere Firma entwickeln dazu
gerade den Dual flugetreaktor mit dem
Kern Energie um ein Vielfaches
effizienter genutzt werden kann und
somit auch die Stromkosten erheblich
gesenkt werden können gleichzeitig ist
der dual-reaktor durch die geschickte
Nutzung einfacher physikalischer
Prinzipien inhärenz sicher nebenbei
übrigens fallen hier auf Dauer keine
radioaktiven Abfälle an die über
geologische Zeiträume gelagert werden
müssten und damit wir in einigen Jahren
nicht wir wieder ohne Fortschritt
zusammensitzen und über die gleichen
Themen diskussieren sollte diese
Entwicklung genau jetzt massiv verstärkt
werden die Lage ist dramatisch das waren
ganz viele Experten das wissen wir auch
jeder versucht zu sparen jeder fragt
sich und was für ein Winter gehen wir da
sie haben ihre ganz persönliche Lösung
vorgeschlagen reden wir gleich gerne
darüber einmal möchte ich aber wissen
was muss die Politik jetzt ganz konkret
und zwar vor allem ganz schnell umsetzen
damit sich die Lage also es gibt die
sogenannte Marit order Folge der
Kraftwerke nach denen die sogenannten
Grenzkosten eingeteilt werden und
Berechnung zeigen dass allein durch die
Zuschaltung von den bereits
stillgelegten drei Kernkraftwerken und
natürlich der Weiterbetrieb der jetzigen
Kernkraftwerke die Stromkosten massiv
senken können weil der Sprung zu Kohle
einfach sehr hoch ist denkt man ein viel
weiteren Leistungsbereich ab und deshalb
wäre es jetzt ganz enorm wichtig um über
den Winter zu kommen die auch nicht nur
die jetzigen Kernkraftwerke aktiv
weiterlaufen zu lassen nicht einfach nur
im Standby-Betrieb sondern auch zu
rüsten natürlich für den nächsten Winter
und auch die restlichen stillgelegten
drei noch funktionsfähigen Kraftwerke
wieder in Betrieb zu nehmen die Zeit ist
jetzt eigentlich schon zu knapp dafür
also es bedarf schon eine massiven ein
Anstrengung aber das muss getan werden
und für die Zukunft natürlich weil der
nächste Winter wieder kommt es wird
wieder genauso sein die Kernkraftwerke
inzwischen dann in der Zwischenzeit
entsprechend zu rüsten wieso sehen Sie
die Gefahr dass es Stromabschaltung gibt
in Deutschland die wurden ja bereits
angekündigt und das Problem ist man
verlässt sich man hat sich bisher immer
auf die Franzosen verlassen die ja genau
den sicheren kann Energiestrom geliefert
haben nun sind aber durch die
corona-zeit die Wartungsarbeiten so
aufgeschoben worden dort das im Sommer
fast keine Kernkraftwerke mehr liefen
und jetzt zu wenig wieder im Betrieb
gehen und die Franzosen werden zunächst
an sich selbst denken und die heizen ja
auch mit Strom ist das Problem das heißt
wenn der Winter auch noch in Frankreich
kalt wird dann gibt es von den Franzosen
hier keinen Strom und dann aus dem
Grunde wurden ich glaube das war in
Rheinland-Pfalz oder irgendwo in einem
Bundesland wurden bereits Strom private
Stromabschaltung angekündigt worauf
glauben sie müssen sich die Deutschen ja
gefasst machen für viele ist das Thema
noch ein bisschen abstrakt jeder denkt
da droht irgendwas wie schlimm kommt es
wirklich wenn wir da mal ganz konkret
worauf müssen wir gefasst machen glaube
ich ja also es ich glaube nicht so
richtig an einen flächendeckenden Blick
auf das kann natürlich auch immer
passieren die Gefahr steigt einfach bloß
ja die deutschen Ingenieure sind da
immer noch zu clever und lassen sich da
was einfallen dass man es immer noch
schafft Teilbereiche abzuschalten das
Problem ist dass das ein Prozesses den
man gar nicht so in den in den Zeitungen
liest wenn ihr z.B einen wichtiger
industriebe zeitweise abgeschaltet wird
und dadurch eine immenser Schaden
entsteht das ist in der Regel nicht mal
eine Zeitungsmeldung wird aber es führt
dazu dass im Hintergrund die Industrie
schleichend abwandert und das passiert
jetzt im Prinzip schon seit Jahren seit
10 Jahren mindestens das der nächste
Betrieb dann im Ausland in den US
Kommentar oder irgendwo gebaut wird und
wir merken es erst dann wenn ja wenn der
letzte Betrieb hier geschlossen wird
aber dann ist es zu spät dann dauert es
wahrscheinlich Jahrzehnte bis man die
alle wieder zurückholt das ist der erste
sehr wichtige Punkt was konkret jetzt
für den für die Haushalte also für die
Privathaushalte dann zu spüren ist sind
natürlich diese teilabstaltung die mit
kurzer zeitlich sehr kurzer Ankündigung
dann erfolgen werden und da empfiehlt es
sich vorgesorgt zu haben oder man muss
eben dieses Gebiet verlassen oder man
muss sich was einfallen lassen aber das
ist natürlich nicht ganz so gefährlich
wie ein flächendeckend
seit Jahren darüber und ähm wir gehen
zurück ins Sozialismus zurück in der
Zuteilung Abschaltung etc ähm ich habe
auch einen schönen Artikel geschrieben
von vom Wirtschaftswunder zu werden und
ich habe vorgesorgt natürlich ich habe
eine Solaranlage und so weiter und haben
Holzofen aber Fakt ist es zeigt einfach
die komplette Bankrott Erklärung der
Energiewende muss man ganz klar sagen
weil wir werden die Industrialisierung
sehen welche Investor wird jemals in
Deutschland investieren wenn man nicht
Versorgungssicherheit hat wenn man keine
Kosten transparent hat und wir erleben
es ja jeden Tag auf der Stromrechnung an
der Tankstelle beim Einkaufen die Kosten
explodieren ist auch sozialer
Sprengstoff na die hohe Inflation dass
die Kluft zwischen Arm und Reich immer
größer wird und ich kann nur sagen also
die Bundesregierung muss jetzt endlich
und vor allem die Grüne Partei muss die
ihre Ideologie dieser dogmatisch
verblendet muss über Bord werden muss
jetzt wirklich an das Wohl der Menschen
denken und auch in den sozialen Frieden
denken an die Zukunft dieses Landes weil
wenn die Firmen ab wann haben wir
weniger Steuereinnahmen und können dann
auch nicht mehr das Geld zu verteilen
wie bisher aus dem Grund Atomkraftwerke
sind auch EU konform und esg-konform
sind emissionslos ja also Empfehlung
sogar müssen angeschaltet bleiben sind
sicher die sichersten auf der ganzen
Welt in Deutschland und wir müssen
vielleicht sogar wieder Kohle ähm
Gruppen aufmachen die wir erst mit
Milliarden Subventionen geschlossen
haben weil momentan sind wir zum hohen
Teil von Kohle abhängig ja dann hat die
Regierung das erkannt glaubst du dass
die regist
dabei der größte kohleminister aller
Zeiten zu werden könnte man jetzt kurz
sagen wir haben gesehen es gab Tage am
Wochenende da hat der Strom beim der der
die Kohle am Strommix die Hälfte
ausgemacht die Hälfte des Stroms mit
Kohle er wurde produziert dann haben wir
20% Gas gehabt ungefähr sechs Prozent
sechs bis sieben Prozent Kernkraft jetzt
nehmen wir an im mit Blick auf die
nächsten Winter da werden wir ähnliche
lagen haben das ist mal zweieinhalb bis
drei Wochen wenig Wind und wenig Sonne
gibt so wie aktuell seid über zwei
Wochen schon wir werden also wieder
mindestens 50% Kohle brauchen wir werden
dann die Kernkraft ersetzen müssen wir
wissen aber hat Frau von der Leyen auch
gestern wieder gesagt dass das wird eher
knapper im nächsten Winter
also werden wir mutmaßlich auch weniger
Gas für die für die Stromerzeugung
einsetzen können wenn wir da jetzt noch
mal die die Kernkraft wegnehmen mit
sechs bis sieben Prozent und beim Gast
von 20 auf 10 runtergehen dann werden
wir diese mutmaßlich 15 16 %, wenn die
Sonne nicht richtig scheint und der Wind
nicht wird wie aktuell ersetzen müssen
muss man sich durch was durch Kohle und
dann werden wir bei über 50% kohleanteil
sein das ist gigantisch das ist dann
Robert Habeck zuzuschreiben und der
Grünen Partei das bedeutet natürlich
dass Deutschland zur absoluten
Dreckschleuder wird wir sind nach Polen
ohnehin jetzt schon dass dann mit dem
zweithöchsten CO2 Ausstoß gemessen pro
produzierte Kilowattstunde Strom und das
wird nicht weniger werden und wir gehen
aber durch die Welt als der große Klima
und Öko Lehrmeister mit einem ganz ganz
großen erhobenen moralischen Zeigefinger
und das ist an wirklich Doppel Moral
nicht zu überbieten das kann man gar
nicht häufig nur sagen in der macht
offenbar ist es sowas auch Ideologie
gerade richtig gesagt es geht um
Ideologie beim Thema Kernkraft das steht
ganz ganz tief drin diese Anti
akw-bewegung bei den Grünen sind die
Grünen einfach nicht mit rationalen
Argumenten zu überzeugen da geht's
wirklich da ist da ist das dreckige
Kohlekraftwerk ist den Grünen mehr als
das CO2 Arme AKW und das ist doch das
ist doch in der Welt in der wir leben
wenn wir sagen CO2 ist das Problem doch
wirklich nicht rational in der nächste
Punkt die E-Autos die ja angeblich so
frei sind die werden direkt schleudern
ja die werden irgendwann dreckiger sein
als der der brennermotor weil sie
natürlich mit Kohle befeuert werden es
ist wir leben das ist ein absolut
anders kann man das gar nicht
beschreiben aber zu ihrer Lösung wir
haben über die Kernkraftwerke gesprochen
und sie haben einen quasi Mini Version
klären Sie mir was sie da genau bauen
und wie das die Lösung sein kannst wir
arbeiten ja schon länger dran dass seit
zehn Jahren entwickeln wir jetzt seit
anderthalb Jahren in Form einer Firma
ein reaktor-konzept das ja ich würde
sagen die erste zivile Reaktor
Neuentwicklung seit Jahrzehnten
darstellt die der Dual Fluid Reaktor
kann durch sein Prinzip von zwei
Flüssigkeiten im Reaktorkern extrem
klein gebaut werden und wird dadurch
extrem energieeffizient das Konzept ist
natürlich noch nicht wirklich in der
Realität gelaufen das wollen wir jetzt
in den nächsten Jahren angehen und ähm
ja die Wirkung ist dass wir durch den
geringen Materialverbrauch an
Strukturmaterialien ja eine extrem hohe
Energiedichte erreichen und dadurch
können wir das Ganze sehr kompakt bauen
also kann ich mir die Garage stellen
oder das vielleicht nicht ganz aber so
fast kann man sagen man muss es
natürlich einbunkern und dann weil das
ganze so kompaktes kann man es
unterirdisch bauen und damit bleiben im
Prinzip alle Schadstoffe aller
Radioaktivität bleibt immer unterirdisch
eingeschlossen und weil das System auch
drucklos läuft kann dort nicht durch
Überdruck irgendwelche Radioaktivität
nach außen bringen wie viele Jahre
dauert das noch wie viel wird mich das
kosten wenn ich das Loch ausschaffen
will und mir das Ding besorgen möchte
hängt davon ab also natürlich als
regulären Plan dauert es bestimmt 10
Jahre bis man so einen serienreifend
Reaktor entwickelt hat man kann
natürlich wenn ähm ich meine gemessen an
diesen ganzen Klima
Katastrophenszenarien sollte man die
Entwicklung beschleunigen äh das kann
man hier tatsächlich machen dann wird es
natürlich überproportional teurer aber
wenn das so wichtig ist dass man
irgendeine Lösung findet dann würde man
das als ein großes nationales oder
internationales Programm auflegen und
versuchen so ein Reaktor zumindest mal
auszuprobieren entwickeln sie das ja in
Kanada wer ja schön wenn das in
Deutschland Unternehmen entsprechend
aber wir haben auch festgestellt in
Kanada ist es auch nicht so einfach weil
die Behörden tatsächlich immer noch so
sehr auf die guten alten
Druckwasserreaktoren eingestellt sind
und das wird wahrscheinlich in allen
Kernreaktoren betreibenden Ländern
ähnlich sein also wir haben gut wenn es
für dieses Projekt dann Geld gebe damit
wir quasi den Plan B nicht ganz in der
Garage aber vielleicht im Vorgarten
verbuddelt
gehen wir noch mal in die Details und
dann genau also es gibt tatsächlich eben
die Lösung für das Problem auch
gleichzeitig das nukleare Abfall Problem
ich wollte noch eins sagen man kann
tatsächlich mit dem Dual Fluid Prinzip
nicht nur den Sektor Strom abdecken
sondern es ist ja auch ein
Hochtemperaturreaktor und damit kann man
synthetische Kraftstoffe produzieren und
zwar zu einem Bruchteil der Kosten wie
das jetzt für ja nach heutigen
Bedingungen wäre und durch die
dampfreinformationen so heißt das oder
eben sogar zukünftige was man planen mit
den mit Energie
also man kann dann auch den Sektor
Verkehr natürlich ab machen und damit
nicht nur die sektorstrom man kann also
im Prinzip alle Sektoren in der
Wirtschaft damit abdecken also da könnte
man mal Geld reinstecken aber Jan man
steckt jetzt Geld in einen ganz anderes
Projekt und wenn du von dem hörst ist ja
nicht unbedingt zum Feiern zumute man
Jugendliche wird aber vielleicht jubeln
denn man kann jetzt Party machen auf
Staats